hallo leute willkommen zurück aus berlin
heute mit einem neuen thema das wir
schon oft gefordert hat nämlich glaubst
du an verschwörungstheorien gucken wir
mal was die leute auf der straße sein
fragen heute ob ihr an
verschwörungstheorien glaubt gute frage
ja aber ich glaube ich an das wort
verschwörungstheorien weil das es schon
mal dass es nicht nicht wahr ist und es
gibt ja so viele
nein was ist denn dein lieblings
verschwörungstheorie kommt immer darauf
an welche verschwörung
verschwörungstheorien gibt es so was
aber natürlich wenn man daran glaubt
empfindet man es nicht als verzierung
sagt es gibt verschwörungs praktiken ja
was haben sie da gehört auch zum
beispiel julius cäsar wurde durch eine
verschwörung umgebracht und also
politische verschwörungen so was gibt es
also also von theorien welche zb ab
jetzt kein beispiel
obwohl doch vielleicht world trade
center der einsturz glaubst du das mal
auf einen kaffee treffen lieblings
verschwörungstheorie die amerika wie war
das noch mal dass die amerikaner gar
nicht auf dem mond gelandet sind sondern
dass das irgendwelche fake video
aufnahmen waren also
verschwörungstheorien
also eigentlich bin ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt derjenige der wirklich daran
glaubt aber ganz ausschließen würde ich
nie und nimmer
ich glaube an definitiv ein paar
formulare es mal anders an was glaubst
du woran die mehrheit der bevölkerung
nicht unbedingt glaubt
chemtrails zum beispiel das besagt diese
theorie also dieses geoengineering dass
das wetter so zusammen beeinflusst wird
von diesen streifen die man da oben seht
also ich glaube nicht nur dass es wasser
dampf ist sozusagen da oben weil das ist
schon ein bisschen verdächtig dass das
unsere zwei stunden oder drei stunden
dann trotzdem ein luft bleibt
hallo liebe leute kelly und jack shear
es angefangen zu regnen
deshalb haben wir uns in ein cafe
zurückgezogen und wir wollen jetzt von
janosch wissen ja es hat eben schon
angefangen immer mit zu diskutieren auf
der straße ja mich was ist denn deine
lieblings verschwörungstheorien eine der
skurrilsten verschwörungstheorien ist
dass wir von außerirdischen regiert
werden die gar keine menschen sind
sondern seine reptilien form haben um
manchmal wenn man den regierungen
richtig in die augen schaut dann sieht
man dass diese geschützte reptilien
augen haben waren die amerikaner dann
auf dem markt wir hatten alles sie 2009
mehr als der tiefste nico beck
stellenmarkt also nirgendwo
gaza inn wusste das problem an
verschwörungstheorien ist ja auch dass
die leute die daran glauben
die würden das ja nicht als
verschwörungstheorie bezeichnen
das ist ja gerade das wort für die leute
von denen man glaubt dass sie etwas
irres glauben wie hält man für
verschwörungstheoretiker glauben sie an
verschwörungstheorien eigentlich
generell nicht also weder so 9 die löwen
noch irgendwie dieser quatsch wo die
flugzeuge so ein zeug versprühen also
eigentlich zeitig kompletter blödsinn
kennen sie ein paar
verschwörungstheorien ja diese
landung auf dem mond geschichte und
solche sachen also ich hab viele aber
halt alles vielleicht spaß ich mal
darüber zu reden bei einem bier arbeit
glaubt er nicht wirklich dran jetzt
glaubst du wer das macht quasi extra das
natürlich die frage ob das nun ob das
nun ob das im rockefeller und rothschild
sind das noch mal eine andere
verschwörungstheorie die beiden oder ob
das mutti ist die das macht hier
wer weißt du ja das glaube ich nicht ich
glaube ehrlich gesagt dass er big
companies sind die das machen um weiß
nicht was ich weiß auch nicht den zweck
dahinter muss ich ehrlich sagen warum
man das machen sollte aber ich kann mir
schon vor
es ist schon ziemlich verdächtig uns
dass elvis presley in bielefeld wohnt
das finde ich gar nicht ganz gut und das
ist mir fällt gar nicht gibt genau heute
gewesen dass paul mccartney schon 1966
gestorben ist und seitdem einen
doppelgänger von ihm unterwegs ist habt
ihr gelernt jetzt john f kennedy vom
geheimdienst ermordet wurde mir gut ich
hatte irgendwann mal diesen diesem
bericht gelesen es war so ein kompendium
da kam eigentlich eher aus dass die
mafia wohl dahinter stecken da ja die
kennedys einen alkohol schmuggler
kleinbahn der dann als john f kennedy
präsident wurde so ein bisschen versucht
hat die vergangenheit legen zu lassen
so war das der alte geschäftskontakte
sozusagen gekappt hat kannst du so leute
im freundeskreis sie irgendwelche solche
sachen glauben
dankenswerterweise nicht wenn du leute
kennen lernst du reagierst du denn die
frage wird wie stark sie davon überzeugt
sind und zwar ist beim thema wechseln
wenn man sie nicht vom gegenteil
überzeugen hat aber an die haben
sozusagen wie wir also wer
antisemitische verschwörungstheorien zum
beispiel
wenn er haus schaffen hat der spaß
angenommen also leute unmittelbar davon
betroffen sind hat er spaß also durchaus
dass das keine terroristen waren die von
osama bin laden dahin geschickt wurden
sondern dass das jemand anders gesagt
hat da ich glaube schon dass es
terroristen waren aber ich sag mal der
eigentliche übeltäter ein ganz anderer
war nämlich keine ahnung ich weiß auch
nicht würde wahrscheinlich jeder gern
wissen aber wenn es irgendwas stimmt da
nicht mehr geschehen meistens auch
jemand kennengelernt ich dachte oh das
ein ganz netter
werden irgendwie eine stunde geredet und
plötzlich hin gehandelt zu erzählen dass
quasi alles in der welt von amerika
gelangt ist und sie quasi für alle
kriege alles verantwortlich sind was es
gibt
kennst du solche auch trifft man immer
mal wieder aber ich finde der nachdemo
gestimmt und woran ich auch glaube ist
in amerika und in australien machen die
chlorid ans wasser und flori dessen
nervengift und was diesen pannier
gelernt das dritte auge sozusagen
langsam abbauen lässt
und ich glaube daran dass der government
also der staat das rein macht ins wasser
damit die spirituellen fähigkeiten
weniger werden angesprochen
daran glaubt kappen kollegen der held
nicht so viel ganz unwahrscheinlich gut
war auch nicht wirklich nicht so richtig
aber so für total abwegig hält aber auch
nicht weil irgendwas könnte ja dran sein
nicht dass wir alle manipuliert sind
oder wirklichkeit von aliens beherrscht
werden es ist ziemlich unwahrscheinlich
also ich denke glaube nicht dass ich
fremd manipuliert bin so viel geld eine
chemotherapie gemacht und ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass ist schon längst
ich weiß ist also zum beispiel muss nur
irgendwie in amazonas gehen wenn du
krebs us sucht den charme bleibt
irgendwie vier monate oder so im urwald
und du hast kein krebs danach mehr recht
wenn du etwas kann nimmst und so weiter
weil jede krankheit glaube ich wird hier
produziert im kopf und wenn dein kopf
dein mindset so verändert wird dass du
nicht mehr an die krankheit glaubst dass
du daran glaubst dass du gesund wirst du
gesund bin ich der festen überzeugung
und letzte frage wenn ihr so jemand
kennen lernt und der euch irgendwas
erzählt sondern völlig abstruse theorien
die er wirklich klappt wie reagiert ihr
land
überrascht stückchen ist es
wahrscheinlich ähnlich wie wenn man so
gerüchte hört bisserl was immer dran
für dieses aufgebauscht wie dies auch
frei erfunden also von daher das muss
man im einzelfall für sich prüfen
unter dem thema pharmaindustrie nachname
in asien ist zum beispiel so dass du den
arzt immer bezahlt wenn du gesund bist
wenn du krank bist du auf zu bezahlen
das heißt die ärzte machen geld mit
gesunden menschen und nicht mit kranken
menschen und dass dieses system in
deutschland in der westlichen welt was
so ein bisschen faktor preis stimmt dass
liebe asiatische zuschauer
schreibt uns das mal in die kommen hab
ich gehört er liebe leute das war unsere
heutige episode zum thema
verschwörungstheorien und wir hoffen ihr
habt viele interessante neue theorien
kennengelernt
schreibt uns doch mal in die kommentare
was ist eure lieblings theorie woran
glaubt ihr was haltet ihr für völligen
unsinn
und wenn ihr lust habt dann freuen uns
sehr über eure unterstützung wir haben
gestern erst unsere usa tour angekündigt
ja wir kommen in die usa im oktober wir
wollen euch besuchen und dafür sammeln
wir geld und ideen wo wir hinfahren
können
schaut mal hier neben mir in das video
dort findet ihr alle informationen
danke fürs zuschauen und bis bald bei
easy german